Supplementary must mean that the two angles add up to 180 degrees. We can see
that because angle R and angle Q add up to 180. This should also make sense,
because a circle has 360 degrees. So, if I take half of it or draw a straight
line through it, I know that's only 180 degrees, just like in this case. So, if
angle S and angle T are supplementary, they must add up to 180 degrees. I knew
angle S measures 55 degrees so I just need to find the measure of angle T. You
can either think about it in your head or just subtract 55 degrees from both
sides. So, T is equal to 125 degrees. You might be saying, whoa, this doesn't
make sense. This angle is smaller than this angle and you're right. Well, it
turns out that this diagram isn't to scale. This would be a more accurate
picture of our angle measures. We could find angle V in a similar fashion. We
know U and V have to add up to 180 degrees and then, we subtract 12 degrees from
both sides. So, V must be 168. If you got those two right, nice work.